when you play quarterback in the nfl you
were a leader of men i mean that's
something my dad used to say to me when
i first got into the nfl hey hey
christopher don't forget you're leading
men out there you would tell my mom a
diana diana you can't you can't go to
the game yeah you just can't i just not
safe i don't i don't trust it if we were
sitting around the family room and i
asked them some of the questions that i
asked them in an interview i'd get an
answer like oh
crap christopher i don't know so long
ago i can't remember but when there's an
audience or a microphone i always hear
new stories from my dad
that's some chris sims talking about his
dad phil sims and chris's default voice
anytime he's trying to impersonate
anyone it's his impression of you yes
every time that's the only voice he can
do yes and you know what's really sad of
course a lot of my friends who have
radio shows they make fun of me that i
ask myself questions and go into this
other guy
and now when i watch you guys every
morning he's doing it yeah so he goes
into well you know people say this and
then he answers the question you know
whatever i just go oh my god so i really
am like that it is he he's like he does
the voice himself sometimes when he's
trying to make fun of somebody and then
i think really our uh my brother
matt matt was the one that really
started to like own it and that's where
it really got me to jump by because he
can imitate anybody and dad he's got
down he's got dad down but the only
person he can imitate is you
before anything
i just want to say i'm sorry
okay and uh i don't know what else to
say uh that's it
and i know i see him
you're sitting next to him those big ass
hands of his you know he always he's
always he does it to me and i'm like i'm
getting old get your damn hands off me
and you know oh well whatever well he
does it to me all the time yes
and i can tell you really love it oh
it's great it's great especially when he
digs his fingers into my leg oh it's the
worst
that's good all right so you're uh
you're got back on your big a little t
here right yes yes do you know what's
real yeah do you drink it i do
occasionally yeah as much as i used to
well you know i
i've been working for them for 15 years
they've never asked me really to do
anything and they asked me this year to
come down i said oh i'm honored to do it
i've been honored to work for the
company they're in fairfield connecticut
and their product is
great i got had to get on a stage once
mike
cindy bigelow who runs the company has
seven tees up there and they're covered
and she makes me do the taste test and
tell me which one was bigelow and i'm
thinking well if i get this wrong there
it goes out the door right and i picked
it out you guessed it i guessed it right
i was sweating bullets i bet you were
that was worse than being in front of
bill parcells after a bad game
but it's worked out yeah they got a lot
of great teas i'm a decaf green tea
drinker you see you got a mike you got
lemon ginger yeah probiotics just last
week when our voice was shot i
definitely could have used it yeah well
that's what it's good for you can tell
when you look at the bag it's like it is
real teeth it's real chopped up crafted
right been painted brown and you know
he's a my son's a germ freak are you he
no i'm not you're not excited i'm gonna
be all over the count all right he's
coughing on me oh well yeah but if you
go to their factory which i have you
could eat off the floors i mean it's
that unbelievable right and the smell of
course is magnificent so
it's a great company and they've been
great to me and joe torre has done some
commercials and
things with me whatever but it's it's
worked out well they got a lot of new
products out so you guys try a few of
them and see what you think there's only
one caveat you got to be careful with
the string you're gonna have a mishap
yeah dude we got that that's right
that's the favorite game ever right here
you never know wait you'll never know
when the bag is going to come out of the
cup you know what's great about that so
it happens and of course we kept it in
the show right because any time you do
something wrong on showtime it's going
on air right so i come in the next week
with a big poster a bigelow t and me on
it hold it and i said to chris
collinsworth
see
they saw that and they got me and i
think he goes are you kidding and he
goes crazy
right dumbbell
he believed you he believed me yeah so
oh well that was good um talk about the
game i mean a little bit just you know
just like your overall thought well i
know you guys i mean
it's
two weeks what else can you say about
the game right but you know i i'm
listening to you guys i do listen to
y'all
every morning i do i might not make the
seven o'clock starting time yeah maybe
second showing at nine yeah for sure
then because i'm already usually working
by then and looking at stuff and i
listen and watch you see how you look
and all that stuff and whatever and some
of the damn things
the things you say
whatever
i don't know what to say but the game
you know it says i look lots of ways to
look at it
can kansas city make san francisco throw
the ball more than they want
and can the san francisco 49ers dare the
kansas city chiefs to run the football
right can they dare him just
line up the defense go go ahead and run
it right and you know you know my lines
about andy reid yeah yeah go ahead give
them they're good
why does andy reed hate to run the ball
on first down mike
why because he hates second and nine
and why do they run it on first down
every once in a while so those wide
receivers can rest up before i send them
down the field again that's true and
it's that's him so even if you dare him
to run and it's there he still might not
do it because
he's been that way his whole career he's
great at it he has adjusted which i've
heard you talk about
we know that some teams have slowed them
down playing a certain style it fits
into san francisco a little yeah it does
and i can't imagine the 49ers even with
their great pass rush is going to just
say we're going to cover them that's
just not their style to try to play them
and we can cover these guys one-on-one i
just don't see that right that's one
thing we've been talking about phil the
idea that the 49ers will just back off
and go very deep and force patrick
holmes to be patient whether it's a run
or a short pass and take away that that
big explosive play that will lift the
team that we see them do with the
deliver the dagger from time to time
it's just not going to be there what's
he going to do if it's not there yeah
well he's got they've done a better job
of throwing it short over the i'd say
the last maybe seven eight nine games
whatever and uh but they don't want to
and it did work that's what the chargers
did they dropped back and dared them and
the 49ers are the perfect team to do
this mike why because you could throw it
in front of him you watched that game
against green bay green bay had plays in
minnesota too that were it was like the
parting of the red sea and there comes
the receiver the runner and they get two
yards because everybody is so fast up
front that look kwon alexander and that
that linebacking core right they cover
up a lot of bad stuff yeah they do yes i
mean it's it's really when i watched
them this week then i turned on a film
yeah to watch the championship game with
the tennessee titans i went damn the
titans look like they're running in slow
motion yeah the chiefs you meant the
chiefs running or no oh you're the
titans got you got you guys because i
was watching san francisco's defense
and then i turned on the titans defense
to watch kansas city's offense i said
they look you know i don't mean this in
a bad way
but the speed the difference was right
away it caught my eye and the more i
watched it the more it stuck with me
yeah um go ahead go ahead there's been a
lot of talk about how kyle shanahan
coaches jimmy garoppolo so i mean you
with bill parcells yes 21. what what
kind of stuff were you hearing from him
in the run-up to the game
oh you know
nice yeah i know he was he was good to
me then uh but you know i look at that
how many times did i throw the ball in
our first playoff game and second one
yeah i mean none i threw it 14 times i
think in the first game and the
championship game i threw it very few
too but you know we threw a lot of
touchdowns you do have touchdowns right
yeah we threw a lot of balls down the
field whatever but the week going into
the super bowl mike we were kind of on a
roll and bill was
not as edgy we practiced unbelievable
you know our practices back then were
real i don't
like we really hit in fact our monday we
had fights
i mean real fights it was like out of
contro because everybody was so jacked
up right but
we were so
precise in practice
that on friday of the before the first
super bowl he said to me after i threw a
pass he goes okay okay
oh man sims you're hot okay no let's uh
and he basically stopped practicing he
goes we're good we're just wasting time
now and uh you know bill was an
interesting guy hard during the week but
really positive as the game was coming
around like beat on you all week and
right before the game maybe on saturday
he goes i just want to tell you man
you're doing a hell of a job right or
something to make you feel good right
because i walked out of the locker room
once
in 1984 my career is on the line his is
too yeah
first game of the year
philadelphia eagles philadelphia eagles
i'm walking out and he says say sims i
go yes coach he goes if you don't throw
at least two interceptions then you're
not trying you're not taking enough
chances i said well i can take care of
those interceptions for you
but you know that was his way of trying
to ease the tension because he always
preached
go for it be aggressive and if you make
the mistake we'll pull it back and you
know find a way to get it done really
really yeah he was a great psychologist
that's for sure yeah it seemed that way
i mean that's what i always get from him
he could play psychologists with anybody
on the on the team well when you look at
jimmy garoppolo too you kind of brought
it up like
what do you what's your take is it fair
the criticism jimmy garoppolo gets get
into the super bowl everybody
questioning him doubting him right now
well that's look that's just is it fair
it's just the way it is come on you guys
know it i mean that's what i heard
probably going to superbowl i can't
remember you know why because i didn't
care right and you know it was a
different atmosphere then too i wasn't
being judged by analytics and all the
numbers and everything that go with it
so you know i found the super bowl week
out in pasadena to be very
good talk to reporters in the lobby
after practice it was
really just
a whole different atmosphere you know
definitely yeah i uh so i didn't get
beat on too much then i just mike lupica
the great writer for the daily news
as i did my last little press conference
sitting around a table eating breakfast
he goes you know phil we're getting
ready to get on the bus mike he goes you
know do you know no matter how you play
even if you play really well the giants
lose it everybody's going to blame you
and i said thank you mike that was great
and then i got up left you know that was
my last question of super bowl week who
which was true i knew who was the guy
during your career that that you would
have liked to have stuffed into a trash
can was it lupica or somebody else no no
i love mike lubica
you know the question because the
question was it was true and i knew it
right and i i went to dinner with our
good friends the boxes yeah the night
before we left and and i just sat there
and i just said
my friend said man phil you know
they're going to blame you and i say
randy shut up
but i didn't say that but i said yeah i
know i know i know that's on the line
and i think most quarterbacks know
now for sure mike that you go to the
super bowl you lose somewhere they're
going to pin it on somebody yeah oh you
can't win the big one you didn't come in
the big moment all those kind of things
so
but jimmy garoppolo to answer your
question i'm sorry getting getting all
right
he will
i'll be shocked
if they don't get him off to a good
start right that's that's what i think
that's all we've been saying yeah
short passes you got to do it you got to
at least make the defense think and you
know those kind of things and and then
just get them thinking a little bit
spread them out whatever it is and then
of course when it's
all said and done they're always going
to try to go back to the run game yeah i
know you would think that yes shanahan's
aware of everything around it too he
wants to get this guy off to a feeling
good and everything like that the only
negative that is yeah
steve pagnola i mean yeah he could be
scary hell he he doesn't have he doesn't
say oh i'm gonna he you never know what
he's gonna worry about tyrant matthew
too reading what's coming seeing what's
coming being in the right place at the
right time and jimmy garoppolo throws
that pass and well there's tyron matthew
and everything pops right there how
about that though how about him tyron
matthew what a comeback year and then
when they signed him i went oh i don't
know about that he has i have like
crushed on him about the last six weeks
show time and everything i just thought
oh and then on the seam in person the
energy that he has and the way he talks
to everybody and i heard you say andy
reid said he took over the locker room
right away right so he's the guy they
got the guy that was drafted out of lsu
that played really well for the
cardinals and then of course when he got
hurt it took a couple years for him to
get back to where he is and he's been
terrific you know i'm concerned that one
of these two teams is going to deliver
an early uppercut knockout and it's
going to not be the close exciting game
that we're hoping for i think that's
very possible yeah i've said it i've
said that too uh you know this game
could be
35 21 it could be 35 17. i don't think
the chiefs
will be that team to get the knockout
punch if somebody's gonna get it done
early or get a spread where it's hard to
overcome right i think that would be the
49ers would be my guess just because i
just think the 49ers athletically
are
better
uh but that doesn't mean you're going to
win uh but i just think physically the
49ers have a little edge over over the
kansas city chiefs all right well that's
hard to say no patrick mahomes and all
those receivers scary i know it's crazy
but all right so let's go let's hear it
who's going to win the damn super bowl i
want to bid the pick i want an mvp we've
had a bunch of guys today who have have
weaseled out of the quest yeah we know
that you will not weasel out oh no i've
already said it i i'm i'm going to say
san francisco 34-21
over kansas city wow and i think the
game will be close but it'll get lost in
the end or whatever yes that's i i i
think it's possible so i'm taking san
francisco i'm just going with the
faster
boy it's hard to say that i know faster
or more physical team they are overall
they're just not a wide receiver yeah
the wide receiver position is the the
gold medal went in track team which i've
been saying for a while so but uh yeah
so i'm not no i won't weasel out i've
been doing this every year i always do
it
and i had a terrible year picking games
i don't know how'd y'all do he beat me i
didn't know like i did i mopped up the
floor with him
i can tie him actually in just regular
doesn't matter this week people don't
care about that they care about the
spread against the spread it's too
embarrassing to
i feel badly for him but i will say i am
truly been on a hot streak in the super
bowls yeah big time okay last year i set
it on air seconds before the kickoff
i like the patriots the score is going
to be lower than everybody thinks but i
like them and i basically said i like
them
they were favored yeah covered too i
said i didn't say cover yeah but i
basically said yeah right right all
right it's amazing how the world's
changed you can take cover now yeah it
really is and over and everything yeah
we're actually on show time we pick
games against
the spread every once in a while well
don't get input from him because he's no
good at it yeah well help hey mike if i
was good at it i wouldn't be sitting
here there you go i mean it's the
hardest thing to bet on and to win at is
pro football definitely no doubt about
it well any variables and i haven't hit
you in a minute yeah thank you it's
great that you're here it's not great
that he's here but i feel like i feel
like you're my dad too even though i'm a
lot i'm close we could be closer to
brothers really but i hear about you all
the time from him and i like it all
right all right we'll be back with more
pfd live
we all have across the barren life mike
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports